on commence par marine le pen qui a
glissé son enveloppe dans l'urne après
11 heures à hénin beaumont dans le pas
de calais anne hidalgo eric zemmour qui
ont voté voilà tout au long de la
matinée valérie pécresse était dans les
yvelines alors pendant cette quinzaine
est muni de son passeport l'ex-candidate
lr a tout de même pu glisser son
bulletin dans l'urne les expatriés ont
déjà exprimé leur vote et puis ceux qui
sont à shanghai ocs chine
malheureusement eux sont privés de vote
ont également voté les premiers
ministres d'aujourd'hui et d'hier jean
castex edouard philippe ainsi que
l'ancien président françois hollande on
va entendre donc le président et ce
moment solennel du président sortant qui
donc vote pour ce second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
il n'y a pas de sang sur france info
c'est pas grave si vous nous rejoignez
de toute manière vous le savez vous la
connaissez cette expression a voté le
premier chiffre que nous pouvons vous
donner ce soir c'est celui de la
participation regarder elle est de
71,4 %
c'est tout simplement la plus faible
participation jamais enregistrée depuis
1969 depuis 53 ans
[Musique]
majoritairement 50% ont repoussé la
proposition de marine le pen
incohérences et une partie de ces
propositions qui était franchement je
n'ai pas violé d'axa et donc c'est la
dispersion de la corne est un taux
d'abstention extrêmement fort un vote
utile enfin on a matraqué pour le vote
utile dès le premier tour est
aujourd'hui un rassemblement national à
42% donc ça interroge moi je rejoins
gabriel atteint là dessus ça appelle à
la responsabilité ça appelle pas à
l'autosatisfaction j'ai entendu parmi
certains de vos collègues tout à l'heure
avec plus de 43% des voix le résultat de
ce soir représente en lui même une
éclatante victoire
le troisième tour comment ce soir
les 12 et 19 juin au lieu les élections
législatives
vous pouvez battre monsieur macron et
choisir un autre chemin je crains ce
soir que le quinquennat qui s'ouvre ne
rompra pas avec les pratiques méprisante
et brutale du précédent et qu emmanuel
macron ne fera rien pour réparer les
fractures qui divise notre pays et font
souffrir nos compatriotes alors oui pour
éviter cet accaparement des pouvoirs par
quelques uns plus que jamais je
poursuivrai mon engagement pour la
france et les français c'est la huitième
fois que la défaite frappe le nom de le
pen
je voyais cette défaite venir depuis des
années et ce n'est vraiment pas de
gaieté de coeur que je l'annonçais j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu pour éviter ce
résultat après cinq années
de transformation de re re est difficile
de crise exceptionnelle aussi
ce jour du 24 avril 2022 une majorité
d'entre nous a fait le choix de me faire
confiance pour présider notre république
durant les cinq années à venir ce soir
pardon nous dire que quelques instants
je souhaite avec mes amis et savourer
cette victoire parce qu'elle est large
et qu'elle signifie aussi que les
français n'ont pas voulu de l'extrême
droite je pense enfin à ceux qui ont
voté pour madame le pen dont je sais la
déception de ce soir non
je citerai personne
depuis le début je vous ai demandé de ne
jamais sifflé